all right I do need to give an update
about what is really a difficult
situation here at the show I've not
talked about this since May 3rd so it's
been more than a month since I talked
about this but we are still suffering
pretty significantly at the hands of the
YouTube advertiser boycott and there's
this difficult situation where I don't
want to talk too much about this but I
also need to talk about it every once in
awhile so people in the audience know
that this is still something that we're
struggling with condensed 30-second
version of what happened
March 31st in response to some public
outcry and articles that YouTube ads
were showing up on inappropriate content
YouTube turned on a new ad algorithm and
what this had is a side effect was that
it cut off almost all ads from the David
Pakman show YouTube channel this is a
problem for us because nearly half of
our revenue was coming from YouTube
which disappeared overnight during the
April and early May period ads sort of
fluctuated going anywhere from 10 to 35
percent of where they previously were
and they've now basically settled and
again the last time I talked about this
was May 3rd in the last month plus a few
days we have settled at about two-thirds
of the number of ads as we used to have
on YouTube each ad paying roughly half
as much simple third grade
multiplication of fractions tells us 2/3
times 1/2 is 1/3 so we're earning about
1/3 of what we were on YouTube
we were hoping that things would improve
during May and they didn't and and at
this point Pat this just kind of appears
to be the new normal we've been waiting
and waiting for this to sort of improve
you've been watching it I've been
watching it the audience has been
watching it and I think at this point it
makes sense to go back to the audience
and just sort of update them on what's
going on because this does appear to be
the new normal on YouTube for producers
like us it's kind of like that thing you
always talk about which is solutions
that don't work the problems that don't
exist basically I mean the the problem
with the YouTube ad algorithm has never
been that it was 2 lakhs
it's always been that it was too strict
or if we talk about Isis or if we talk
about you know Russia or the
israeli-palestinian conflict the videos
don't earn
money so they're trying to solve a
problem that quite literally doesn't
exist so I'm going to the audience I
mean I have this is this is what I have
as a resource the audience is a we have
to go to you because you're our number
one source of funding so there's really
three things you can do and it's it's
really never been more important than
this number one really four things
number one you can get a membership at
david pakman.com slash membership if the
normal rates are a bit high you can use
the coupon code
I voted 17 that's art that's been around
for years and we need your support there
number two we have roughly 1500 people
who have made a pledge at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is simpler
than membership you just go to
patreon.com/scishow the Packman show and
make a pledge of as little as a dollar a
month okay any amount is welcome but you
can pledge as little as a dollar a month
number three if you ever shop on Amazon
you go to david pakman.com slash amazon
before you shop and number four you can
get gear t-shirts coffee bumper stickers
at david pakman.com slash gear we have
had a great response from the audience
we've had a number of new members we
have patreon donors that are
accumulating as you can see from our
page patreon.com/lenguin
just below 1500 patrons but we need to
keep it going
and i'm trying to find the balance i
need to tell you that this is not a good
situation for us but i also don't want
to fill up the entire show with this so
we'll leave it at that
david pakman.com slash membership
patreon.com slash david pakman show